кажуть Влада розбещує абсолютно Влада
розбещує абсолютно і це Та ситуація коли
у
монобільшості вперше в українській
історії ні з ким не треба домовлятися Да
в парламенті А можна було приймати любі
рішення
але навіть при цьому при цьому
захотілося ще щоб ніхто там не знімав
ніякі там СМСки хто пише Та а щоб ніхто
не заважав і ніхто не бачив Що наприклад
голосування за принципові речі такі як
наприклад забрати ПДФО військове з
громад щоби це голосувалося разом з опзж
наприклад і тільки цими голосами там був
шанс це витягнути та
тобто Ось ця небажання звітувати перед
суспільством от воно призводить до того
що так комфортніше так зручніше можна
ходити ну от в чому попало то я не
розумію все одно Чому вони вибрали путь
шлях політичної деградації політик - це
публічна професія політик - це людина
яка має бути впізнавана для того щоб ну
принаймні сподіватися на наступних
виборах бути обраним абсолютна
закритість ми не знаємо парламент ми ну
тобто ми з я скажу більшеце я його теж
не знаю якщо чесно тому що ці люди вони
не виступають в переважній своїй
більшості вони не презентують
законопроектів там є Ну буквально
декілька людей які там щось можуть
говорити від імені комітетів а більшість
питаньгу Лариса навіть іде без
обговорення наприклад тобто доповідач
навіть не доповідає від комітету ніхто
не виступає два за два проти там як
регламент вимагає і все і хтось там
вийшов якусь дежурну Ну от просто
абсолютно чергову фразу сказав ніяких от
справді ви знаєте в чому найбільший жах
і чому я розумію суспільство яке каже що
ее ну воно не довіряє українському
парламенту станом на зараз а це вже не
місце для дискусій якщо впродовж
української історії Це було місце
найбільших політичних дискусій і я
впевнена що це було на користь і на
розвиток країні Та то зараз обравши
монобільшість яка з моєї точки зору є от
великим злом яке Ми не маємо більше
допустити у власній політичні історії
та люди побачили До чого це призводить
до можливості монополізації всього
монополізації кожного комітету до
монополізації фактично висвіт ня цієї
роботи от некомфортно їм щоб ходили там
журналісти по другому поверху спочатку ж
до речі журналістів забрали з другого
поверху там де можна було просто підійти
до депутата і поставити запитання оце
було не камільфо я я скажу таким
терміном і відправили туди на гальорку
на третій поверх щоб зверху можна було
познімати ами сказали що третій поверх
Та нащо ви нам там на тому третьому
поверсі ще наші переписки будете знімати
А давайте їх взагалі там киж зві
переписки були яскраві яскраві пам'ятаю
їх значить рух Чесно провів дослідження
і за їхніми оцінками дані на перше
півріччя 23го року найбільш закриті і
непрозорі парламентські комітети свободи
слова регламенту бюджетної зовнішньої
політики погоджуєтеся з висновком таким
А мені просто смішно що свободи слова
найбільш закритий комітет але чого ми
очікували від Нестора я про Свободи
слово ще запитаю про цей комітет
найбільш відкриті трійка лідерів на
першому місці два комітети з питань
гуманітарної Літки здоров'я нації і на
третьому з енергетики це відкриті
комітети що скажете на до такої оцінки Я
так розумію що там є якісь критерії з
цього приводу але це Ну
так насправді дуже символічно тому що з
одного боку свобода слова це вже просто
пародія на демократію коли закрита
Свобода слова але вона в нас закрита в
нас цензура в країні станом на сьогодні
а друга річ коли закритий бюджетний
комітет це теж дуже смішно тому що там
де ділять гроші деньги любять тишину да
Вибачте за російську мову але це якраз я
думаю про це тому що
коли там а до речі комітет гетьмансова
там немає податкової
політики ні туди ні туди він не попав
Можливо десь на якомусь четвертому місці
По закритості я Я думаю що він дуже
впливовий станом на зараз і реально
займається дуже багатьма такими
питаннями які справді впливають серйозно
на економічну політику в державі От і я
не бачила ніколи щоби там журналісти
були допущені наш комітет там
антикорупційної політики в нас завжди
відкриті засідання в ютбі і якщо ми
робимо щось публічне принаймні
розглядаємо питання пов'язані з
міністерством оборони там Да сьогодні з
корупцією то туди журналістів запрошують
і це по-моєму зараз ледь не унікальна да
така історія коли журналісти могли
потрапити прийти поставити запитання Ну
тому що боротьбу з корупцією треба
показувати це важливо зараз для України
Розумієте це не можна приховувати Що з
комітетом зі Свободи слова несторшу чого
вже не очолює Ну я так розумію що він
його вже не очолює він зараз знаходиться
в СІЗО і десь я так чула такі чуки що
дуже ні звичайно але вирок суду я думаю
він буде і буде дуже серйоз розгляд
справи тому що Наскільки я знаю я не
буду забігати наперед і розказувати але
є дуже серйозні свідчення щодо державної
зради Нестора Шуфрича докази цього Та і
відповідно там був і мотив чому це було
зроблено і є сам фактаж що саме робилося
от всі ці ефіри коли Нестор приходив е
Вибачте іти в прямий якийсь такий
конфлікт ледь не бійку от пам'ятаєте цей
ефір Савіка Шустера з Порошенко з з
бутусовим і все це коригувалося Москвою
все це редагувалося Москвою всі тези
озвучувалися звідти та тобто є підстави
стверджувати що він ці тези отримував і
озвучував і саме тому коли вже його
навіть побили він тоді повертався ну
швидше за все йому там просто-напросто
да Повертайся ти не виконав свою місію і
зараз що це була за місія і Чому так
сталося я думаю це буде відомо і це буде
такий шок і Сенсація А сам комітет ну
Вибачте там було три людини навіть коли
там був Шуфрич тепер його там немає і
там нам зараз іде багато дискусій чи
призначити людину з груп на керувати цим
комітетом тобто в нас є ви знаєте групи
які сформовані з колишнього пзж Тобто
там от керівництва парламенту досі є ця
теза що опозиція - це всі тільки не
європейська Солідарність от А от і ми не
маємо права Віддати їм там жоден комітет
вони не мають права його очолювати
навіть якщо їм є Що казати І навіть якщо
в них є програма дій для для цього
комітету це можуть бути групи або
повноваження цього комітету
просто-напросто передадуть як предмет
відання до комітету з прав людини такий
варіант те Тото Ви писали Про те що
комітет може бути ліквідований як такий
отце буде об'єднання з іншим комітетом
щодо Шуфрича чи прогноз Чи можливий
такий прогноз що він як Медведчук буде
обміняний у Кремлі на когось Ну я думаю
що це не до мене питання бо я не
займаюся обмінами ви бачите та е Я
вважаю що він може бути можливий бо
несар шуферич точно є носієм надзвичайно
чутливий для Кремля і для особисто кума
Путіна Віктора медведчука інформація і
ця інформація Вона ще не на поверхні
тому думаю я би цього дуже не виключала
І я так розумію що в Україні є кого
забирати 2 000 азовців і морпіхів досі в
російському полоні тому предмет для
розмови може бути так якщо його захоче
вести Кремль ми проаналізували роботу
парламенту закритість парламенту роботу
комітетів звісно не глибоко але ми
розуміємо що там відбувається Сьогодні я
натрапила на матеріал на ресурсі
реанімаційного пакету реформ і
поставлене питання Коли в Україні мають
відбутися чергові парламентські вибори у
2023 ро році чи в 24-му я щиро вірила що
в 24му Але бачу пояснення що фактично
якщо міряти від тих дочасних ви які були
проведені після виборів президента
Зеленського То в неділю яка остання
неділя жовтня мали би відбутися
парламентські вибори питання про
легітимність цього парламенту як хто хто
дасть відповідь
А да складне питання тому що я теж
вважаю що Цієї осені мали би відбутися
парламентські вибори і цьому завадила
якраз саме повномасштабне вторгнення
дійсно Конституція склад регулює ці
питання вона не регулює До речі питання
президентських виборів але щодо
парламентських фактично забороняє їх
проведення В умовах воєнного стану і
Знаєте тут нам доводиться тільки
підводити певні підсумки тому що да
вичерпався ось цей от умовно кажучи
парламент
монобільшості проголосований слідом за
Володимиром Зеленським обравшим нові
його обличчя які Він вибрав яких не
знала країна але знала одне прізвище
Володимир Зеленський обравши ці нові
обличчя от він зараз цей Парламент має
прозвітувати принаймні перед українцями
А що було зроблено от ви знаєте Я думаю
що окрім зняття депутатської
недотерканності яке підняло легітимність
цього парламенту і довіру до цього
парламенту до невиданих висот більше то
звітувати особливо нічого тому що навіть
те що тут називається реформами це
легалізація і і горного бізнесу Да яка
не принесла очікуваних результатів зараз
буде легалізація медичного канабісу і
якщо там не буде виправлений до другого
читання суттєвого законопроекту він буде
швидше про виробництво в промислових
масштабах а не про медичний канабіс бо
якраз про медицину там взагалі нічого не
було я сподіваюся що це з'явиться та Ну
напевно ще там Московський патріархат
Московський патріархат Лариса це теж
знаєте ілюзія і дуже прикро що ми
називаємо рішенням те що не є таким
рішен
тому що вибачте але іти в суд на 2000
юридичних осіб і в суді доводити що вони
працюють на державу агресора Це дуже
складна процедура в той час якщо законом
ми могли справді заборонити діяльність
просто-напросто всього що пов'язано з
Москвою і не хоче взяти українську назву
і сказати що це є українська церква
відповідно перереєструватися та тому що
якщо ви подивитеся навіть на сайті
російської Православної Церкви то ви
знайдете українські єпархії там е якщо
йдеться наприклад про Московський
патріархат тобто і ми збираємося в суді
щодо кожної юридичної особи це робити це
пропозиція Кабміну і тільки це винесли
на голосува будуть завалені цими
довготривалими справами дуже складними
справами Тому це не є рішенням насправді
і в нас було рішення ми пропонували
зовсім інший законопроект який міг би
просто зразу ці ну принести результат
але ні бачите все все Ось так от
відбувається Тому зараз потрібен звіт і
зараз потрібен тверезий огляд
суспільства подивитися А до чого
призвела
монобільшість голосування за нові
обличчя но у нейми це дуже важливо зараз
угу Скажіть будь ласка от раз ми
зачепили тему виборів Я так розумію що в
офісі президента там дуже активно
думають що робити з виборами як взагалі
Вийти з цієї ситуації і ну остання
інформація яку я чула серйозно
обговорюють питання референдуму щодо
продовження повноважень Президента
Зеленського оскільки вони не можуть
проводити вибори під час воєнного стану
а це вже квітень наступного року то от
тема референдуму може бути використана
для того щоб люди там ну дозволили
зеленському ще певний час бути на цій
посаді що ви про це думаєте і Чи чули ви
що такі напрямки
обговорюються ну чула Так я не можу
сказати що
Ну не обговорюється Та є різні варіанти
дуже складне питання з виборами тому що
Знаєте а з одного боку ми чудово
розуміємо що
вибори мають відбуватися за правилами
вибори без правил - це не вибори Це не
про демократію да це насправді теж про
узупаці са тому така плутанина Коли
вибори парламенту тому що не за
правилами знаєте дочасні розпустити
парламент і одразу після президентських
робити парламентські ми маємо суцільну
плутанину з виборами по-перше цей момент
Давайте давайте дійдемо До ключових
насправді моментів А як країна живе в
умовах цензу
країна живе в умовах війни а це означає
що просто мільйони людей не зможуть
проголосувати мільйони людей не зможуть
бути обраними і це в першу чергу
стосується військових які
просто-напросто не підеш половина армії
у відпустку для проведення агітації
правда не піде велике питання з
учасником виборів який сьогодні є одним
і ключових конкурентів насправді і
президента Да і правлячої партії може
принаймні ним таким бути Я маю на увазі
головнокомандува залужного та як він
скаже що вибачте Ну там війна
відкладається бо я буду займатися
виборами це використають проти нього
якщо він це зробить з іншого боку якщо
йому не дадуть можливості балотуватися
суспільство буде незадоволене тому що
очевидно що він має Своїх прихильників і
вони мають право за нього проголосувати
безперечно Конституція України вона
гарантує не тільки обирати Алей кожному
бути обраним і ось як реалізувати це
право це є величезне питання далі
спостерігачі Ну ми собі у уявляємо Десь
навіть в Краматорську Я вже не кажу там
часів яр чи там Авдіївка та як там туди
приїхати прийти на дільниці безперечно з
реєстром виборців кажуть що він взагалі
згорів в нас в
лютому 22го року і тепер його якимись
хаотичними засобами пробують відновити
От і поставлені такі такі завдання але
якщо ви запитаєте де в нас реєстр
виборців то Зараз ще буде дуже багато
питань да люди за кордоном електронне
голосування як рішення з моєї точки зору
Це категорично не є рішенням тому що
вибачте але Дія - це прекрасна система
для того щоби ідентифікувати особистість
але саме якщо ви ідентифікуєте
особистість то ви не можете гарантувати
таємницю голосування тому що оператори
дії будуть розуміти Хто і як голосував а
ці оператори дії цеє Держава це є
кабінет міністрів це є прямо люди влади
Тобто це як вони не самі себе мають
обирати чи як Ну тобто якщо ви можете
втрутитися в цю систему зайти до
споживача розуміти хто як голосував дуже
багато питань які скажемо так роблять
фальсифікації більше ніж можливими А що
таке фальсифікації А що таке недопуск
людей що таке неконституційні процеси це
означає що результат цих виборів буде
мати сумнівну легітимність а сумнівна
легітимність означатиме що Знаєте
будь-хто зможе поставити під сумнів і в
міжнародній спільноті Да там які просто
не захочуть Вести перего Говори А ми
сьогодні дуже залежні від міжнародної
спільноти так і серед українців які
просто скажуть Ну так ви нам не лишаєте
іншого вибору окрім як революція а
Україна знала вже багато революцій і цим
точно може скористатися ворог тому є
багато аргументів проти виборів з іншого
боку якщо буде продовжена повноваження
електронним голосуванням
референдумом а чи не відбудеться так що
влада буде зацементована просто-напросто
Та тому е є питання послідовності Я
думаю що на якийсь тільки термін можна
продовжувати отаким голосуванням шляхом
референдумом це може відбутись наприклад
на півроку Ну і чесно кажучи це має бути
відкрита дискусія в суспільстві це це не
має бути кулуарно там десь пошипталися
мені по секрету сказали Інсайдери яких я
не буду називати і оце ми з вами в
студію обговорюємо розумієте але ми
обговорюємо але на Марафоні до речі та
цього навіть цього не обговорюють і
напевно через те вини в ефірі сьогодні в
цифровому а тільки в ютбі Угу де не може
українська влада дістатися і в
відключити бо як ви могла то дістали в
бі в нас достатньо зараз підписників
хочеться більше звісно друзі
підписуйтеся так що у нас з місцевим
самоврядуванням роки від місцевих
виборів жовтень це взагалі в Україні
місяць виборів був колись в мирний
час те що я бачу катастрофічна ситуація
з місцевим самоврядуванням хочуть його в
нього забрати значну частину повноважень
Поясніть ваше бачення Ну ви знаєте Я
думаю що це певні ревнощі влади до
популярності мерів на тих виборах які в
від булися три роки тому ми чітко
побачили
що Мери є ну фактично пожиттєвими
завдяки До речі реформі децентралізації
яку робила Наша команда тому що коли там
в містах з'явилися гроші і в громадах а
то звичайно Мери могли показати свою
ефективність насправді Це дійсно була
суперруспішна реформа яка дозволила
громадам розвиватися знизу і вони були
носіями високої довіри високого рейтингу
від них значною мірою ну залежала
Центральна влада і саме тому що в них
була гроші в них були гроші і можливість
щось робити щоб Люди бачили що вони це
роблять і тому тут є декілька таких
моментів по-перше А що робить зараз
Влада забирає ці гроші податки в
центральний бюджет і друге Що робить
влада це підриває авторитет мерів ви
бачите всі Мери які не від не від слуги
народу Вони сьогодні фактично
відсторонені там ще залишається здається
Борис Філатов в Дніпрі Але
тампевні да Кличко в Києві але постійно
якісь такі спроби є але Вибачте те за що
відсторонили наприклад мера Рівного
через суд Угу Ну це ж абсурд ну людина
підписує мер Як голова міста він
підписує премії
і тут значить йму хтось вбачив конфлікт
в інтересів якісь премії не такі вже там
велика сума людині яка колись з ним там
десь працювала а потім стала його
підлеглою ну ну абсурдно абсолютно таке
рішення судове і воно призвело тим не
менш до відсторонення фактично мійського
голови тому Це очевидно
політично-замовні справи І вони в першу
чергу покликані взяти під контроль
регіони країни І не дати
інструментів людям на місцях мерам на
місцях головам отг бути успішними і ВС ю
наприклад реконструкцію країни відбудову
країни відповідно до цього тепер будуть
проводити через державні агенції які
будуть керуватися з центру і там окремі
люди будуть просто-напросто піаритись на
тому це все про бажання піару це все не
Про реформи не про європейський устрій
який є держава громад Да і мала би бути
держава громад це все про бажання
піаритися і втримувати владу шляхом а
рейтингу однієї людини зрозуміло ви
членкині комітету з питань
антикорупційної політики Я хочу запитати
ідея Володимира Зеленського посилити
покарання за корупцію і прирівняти її до
державної зради під час війни
уже ліквідована чи ще вона живеми Ніні
вона помирає я би
сказала Ну на рівень комітету Вона не
доходила немає такої ініціативи Тобто
вона була проголошена але не була
оформлена у відповідний законопроект в
комітет вона не заходила і за моїм
відчуттями вона таки помирає вона не
була сприйнята нашими закордонними
партнерами бо Фактично це означало дуже
просту річ давайте справи набу заберемо
і передамо в СБУ да ну ну і ще Олег
Татаров писали медіа що курував
підготовкою цього законопроекту
співрозвовники з офісу президента із
антикорупційних структур з медіа
спілкувалися знову ж таки без прізвищ І
от говорили що Татаров саме курує коли
звучить прізвище татарова якось стає
трішечки ну некомфортно розуміти До чого
це може призвести не вірити в
реформаторські зусилля ну сумніваюся Ну
я думаю що суспільство теж і міжнародні
партнери теж і тому от це тиск
міжнародних партнерів чи за все че Я
читаю що в Верховну Раду зареєстрували
новий проект про посилення Незалежності
спеціальної антикорупційної прокуратури
і там теж є застереження що Мінюст може
блокувати певні пункти цього
законопроекту я так розумію що все
впирається в те що сап може порушувати
справи проти народних депутатів так
А я не думаю що це тільки про народні
депутатв якщо там є посилення
повноважень Мінюсту то зновутаки ми не
повинні оці антикорупційні органи і їхні
повноваження розмивати будь-якою іншою
структурою де просто ми розуміємо
монобільшістю чи президентом буде
призначатися керівник чи міністр служби
безпеки України наприклад Чи Міністр
юстиції який Просто може бути замінений
в любий момент тобто з антикорупційною
інфраструктурою там все-таки є процедура
конкурсів там є процедура обрання
включно з міжнародними експертами Які за
це голосують Тобто там складніша
процедура і відповідно більший рівень
захищеності і Незалежності і не хочеться
це розмивати бо Як тільки ми це розмиємо
то ми отримаємо дуже багато Ну зазіхань
скажімо так і плутанини то прагнення
Незалежності буде нівельовано залежністю
абсолютно і до цього прагнуть скажемо
багато хто тому що це зручніше
комфортніше якщо ти у владі але це точно
суперечить тій логіці з якою ці
антикорупційна інфраструктура
створювалася і вона все-таки має зараз
показати результати І я думаю що Ну ми
багато речей вже і бачимо хоча в мене
там наприклад ну там нема особливо
питань зараз і до продуктивності служби
безпеки інша справа що їхня політична
ангажованість Ну вона все-таки теж існує
Хоча вони там зараз досить якісно
працюють
із там наводчиками зрадниками і іншими
речами ми це ми це все бачимо так само в
плані там антикорупційного суду Ми так
само бачимо ну досить багато
продуктивних та
вироків Сьогодні я думаю з цим пов'язана
Ось ця ось остання оцінка що люди от
бачать зусилля да тобто в першу чергу це
мають бути зусилля правоохоронних
органігу звісно 10 жовтня президент
підписав закон про відновлення
електронного декларування і вже фактично
документи мають готуватися тому що за
21й22-й рік документи мають подані до
31 січня тобто лишилося тут три місяці
як ви відчуваєте ну атмосфера яка що там
всередині парламенту ви знаєте всередині
парламенту Я думаю що парламентарі
однозначно там задекларуються в мене є
багато питань як буде декларуватися
депутати місцевих рад насправді і люди
які виїхали за кордон і їм буде все-таки
складніше отримати якісь довідки якісь
речі такі Да Хоча зараз запевняє нас
назк що більшість з бази будуть
підтягуватися інформації про це от тим
не менш питання залишається насамперед
от Якраз для людей з тих регіонів які
дуже постраждали від агресії де були
знищені документи які побували в
окупації або ну тобто всі ці речі Вони є
Ну насправді для тих чиновників і для
тих місцевих депутатів вони можуть
будуть проблематично але запит
суспільний очевидний суспільство хоче
подивитися хто як прожив
цю ну скажемо цю війну
і і тут важливо показати хто чим
займався Да
і і що було там придбано за цей період
часу тому що ви бачили по ТЦК дуже
багато розслідувань сьогодні є по вонко
Ну от знову
таки Ну цкво інкоматів я маю на увазі
тут одне і теж звісно але є в
суспільства сьогодні багато питань і на
них треба давати відповідь і депутатам і
міністерству оборони чиновникам які
займаються закупівлею Да і там
чиновникам на місцях і місцевому
самоврядуванню так само да тому що ми
всі відповідальні сьогодні перед країно
Ну і як же без Мар'яни безуглої
європейська Солідарність вимагає
виключити і з комітету нацбезпеки
оборони фракція хоче публічного
вибачення звертається до Шуляк аби це
сталося це
станеться я не пам'ятаю таких публічних
вибачень від правлячої партії і
зновутаки це монобільшість яка розбещує
Та то от моновлада яка розбещує і це
дуже прикро тому що зараз ідеться про
вибачення насамперед перед родинами
загиблих членів партії не має права
зараз ніхто писати що там рота з
Європейської солідарності щось буде
здавати Іловайськ Дебальцево тому що
люди гинуть для того за те щоб звільняти
і захищати українську землю гинуть наші
партійці і це дуже боляче насправді тому
що всі ці прощання Лора це дуже це дуже
боляче
і стібатися з цього знаєш це спроба
перенести Ось на зараз те що вони робили
в 19-му році коли було знецінювалося все
що робив п'ятий президент України все що
робила Наша команда по відбудові армії
по по будівництву нових ракетних програм
все це було знецінено на цьому просто
топтались і оце спроба зробити те саме і
людина просто Мар'яна просто не розуміє
що зараз вже вона влада і має звітувати
топитання продовжується але ситуація
інша